[Music]
Jennifer Lopez and Alex Rodriguez are
still going strong and their fashion
game is hotter than ever the stylish
couple stepped out for another lunch
date in New York City this time
embracing the spring weather in Sunny's
and pastel colors just more proof that
j-rod are one of the hottest and
best-dressed couples in Hollywood right
now who can forget this red-hot number
on JLo and a rod by her side in this
sophisticated gray suit and black tie
the two knocked it out of the park
speaking of JLo recently gushed about
her man's legendary baseball career on
Instagram calling him the greatest of
all time what a gentleman you're very um
actually he is no I know he's a great
guy he's a good guy the cuteness
continued over on Ellen I saw him walk
by and then afterwards I went outside
but for some reason I just felt like
tapping him on the shoulder and saying
hi and I said hi Alex and he was like hi
Jennifer
and I was like yeah and then that was it
and while they look good on each other's
arms they're adorable praises for one
another are definitely why their hashtag
relationshipgoals we're having a great
time she's an amazing amazing girl one
of the smartest human beings I've ever
met and also an incredible mother
you